hey what's up everyone it's marcus
brownlee from mkbhd and uh this is
actually kind of a not a rebuttal video
but a video response in the first place
uh to apple soldier or a mix video uh
comparing the dell uh i'll just show you
guys the uh the macbook pro 17-inch and
the dell
m17x 17-inch laptop so he was comparing
like the prices of the two and just
going over them and like the way he went
through it it was kind of quick but i
mean i'm trying to see
what his point was with the the pricing
of the two machines but i just didn't
see it so i decided to go through with
it myself and actually compare the specs
of the the 17 inch macbook pro and the
m17 starting from the bottom and working
our way up and seeing which one turns
out to be more
so spec for spec the 17-inch macbook pro
there is only one uh you can start from
the bottom at the 17 inch macbook pro so
you hit select
and i'll go to the m17 and continue
customizing so this is the base price of
the n17x so that's 1799
and for the macbook it's 2500 so that's
what it's starting at so i mean
if there is a lower version please tell
me but i'm just i'm just doing this for
myself
so the processor a 2.8 gigahertz intel
core 2 duo
and on the m17 if we go to processor we
are looking at a
2.8 gigahertz intel core 2 duo
so now right now it's 19.99 for the dell
m17 and still 2500 for the macbook now
you can go up to 3.06 and i think you
can go up to yeah quad core processor
i'm not even going to do that so
uh second
ram which was the the big thing you were
talking about was that it cost so much
for ram right now it costs 1 000
to put in 8 gigs of 1066 ram in the
macbook pro so if we go ahead and put 8
gigs of 1066 ram the same exact ram
putting it in the m17 i'm going to go
down to memory the same exact ram
putting it into the m17
is
700
so the price is obviously
is a big difference right now it's 26.99
and 34.99 now there's a hard drive thing
too okay we want we want performance the
only reason we're getting a 17 inch
desktop replacement is for performance
the most i'm really going to move a 17
inch laptop but like i said if you're
going to buy one it's not going much you
know you're going to travel with it on
vacation once in a while
moving it from room to room so i'm
thinking performance so we're going for
a 256 gig solid state hard drive that's
650 upgrade on the macbook and if we go
to hard drive on the dell m17x
it is a 400 upgrade okay
again i'm just i'm just pointing this
stuff out next we go back to the macbook
and
you mentioned in the video you get ilife
okay you get eye work and all that stuff
actually it's not coming it doesn't um
at the base price it doesn't come with
the macbook so you're not going to get
any of the software i work i life you're
not going to get fce you're not going to
get office you're not going gonna get
anything uh with the mac i'm sorry with
the m17 you do get you know you get open
office you get whatever you want open
source um software but again looking at
the base price without any software on
either one this is 3100 and this is well
this is
past 4 100.
so i mean if you can
i mean i'm i was trying to see what you
were saying in your video but i didn't
really see it 100 so if you could
you know just leave me a comment or a
video response or whatever you need to
do to explain how you got the the
macbook to cost less with the same specs
i'm seeing a thousand dollar difference
here between the macbook and i'm not
going to pay a thousand dollars for an
aluminum casing and
an operating system so just let me know
what your thoughts are and leave your
comments below and thanks for watching
guys peace